هل سبق لك القلق بشأن هذه الأنواع من
الآثار الجانبية ،
نعم ، لكن تلك المخاطر المحتملة
تفوقها ، أعتقد أن الفوائد المحتملة
داخل جسم شون دويل
داخل دمه قد تكمن في الطريق إلى
لقاح لـ kovat 19 بعد أقل من شهر واحد من جينوم فيروسات
كورونا الجديدة
بدأت تجارب اللقاح التسلسلية ، وهناك
الآن ما لا يقل عن ست تجارب لقاح جارية ،
بما في ذلك هذه التجربة في جامعة إيموري
وهي جزء من
أولى التجارب السريرية البشرية للمعهد الوطني للصحة ،
ويسمى اللقاح M RNA -
1-73 وشون هو واحد من 45 شخصًا في أتلانتا  في
سياتل التي تعد جزءًا من المرحلة الأولى
من الدراسة التي تختبرها من أجل السلامة ،
أعتقد في نفسي إذا كنت ابني وقد
أتيت إلي وقلت إنني أريد أن أفعل
هذا ، ما الذي سأقوله لك هل
أجريت محادثة كهذه من قبل  مع
والديك أو أي شخص آخر ، نعم ، كانت هناك
محادثات أجريتها مع الأصدقاء
والعائلة ، لكنهم وثقوا في حكمي ،
لذا فإليك طريقة عملها ، لقد أعطيت بعض
عينات الدم لاستخدامها كحوض
لتقييم صحتي بعد الحصول على
اللقاح وأيضًا لاستخدام خط الأساس
لتحديد ما إذا كان هناك أي
نوع من الاستجابة المناعية التي كان جسدي
قادرًا على توليدها والاستجابة للحصول
على اللقاح لاحقًا إذا كان ناجحًا ،
فقد لا يساعد ذلك فقط في الحصول عليه  لقد عاد العالم إلى
طبيعته ، لكنه قد
يغير قواعد اللعبة أيضًا بالنسبة للعلاجات واللقاحات الأخرى ،
لماذا بسبب تقنيته
بدلاً من استخدام الفيروس الفعلي الذي
يمكن أن يتسبب عن غير قصد في حدوث عدوى
أو حتى شكل معطل من الفيروس ،
يعتمد هذا اللقاح على mRNA messenger
الحمض النووي الريبي الذي هو مجرد مخطط جيني
للفيروس يوجه خلايانا
لصنع بروتين شائك فريد من نوعه
لفيروسات كورونا والذي يعد مفتاح الفيروس
لفتح الباب لأنفسنا بمجرد
أن يدرك أجسامنا أن نظامنا
المناعي يجب أن يكون مهيأ لخلق
أجسام مضادة إذا كان يعمل.  مسار
يحتمل أن يكون أكثر أمانًا
وأسرعًا يقصر عملية التطوير من
عقود إلى سنوات أو حتى أشهر
للوصول إلى المرحلة الأولى  مسألة أشهر
هي الأسرع
التي قام بها أي شخص حرفيًا
في تاريخ الفأس والعلم ، لكن السرعة
هي مجرد اعتبار واحد بعد كل شيء ،
إنها تقنية جديدة من الممكن
أنه لا يوجد إنتاج فعلي
للأجسام المضادة حيث إما أن
الرنا المرسال لم يفعل  الدخول إلى الخلايا ،
لم تصنع الخلايا البروتينات منها على البريد الإلكتروني
أو لم يتعرف الجهاز المناعي على
تلك البروتينات أو لم يتعرف الطبيب على الجرعات المنخفضة جدًا.
إيفان أندرسون هو المحقق
الرئيسي للتجربة في جامعة إيموري ،
وهناك احتمال نظري أنه
يمكنك بالفعل رؤية استجابة مناعية محسّنة تمثل
في الواقع
مشكلة في تحديد التعرض اللاحق لـ
kovat 19 وهو ما يسمى
التحسس ويعني أن الجسم سوف
يبالغ في رد فعله في المرة القادمة.  تتعرض
لفيروس كورونا مسببة عاصفة من
الالتهابات المميتة بالإضافة إلى
أي شيء جديد سيكون لدينا مجهولة
ومخاطر يمكن أن تشعر ببعض الألم أو
الرقة في موقع الحقن
كجزء من التجربة يحصل شون على جرعتين
من اللقاح الثاني فقط.  في
الأسبوع الماضي وتابعته من خلال تسجيلات الوصول
وسحب الدم لقياس
التغييرات المحتملة على نظامه في العام التالي
، شعرت حقًا وكأنه لقاح الأنفلونزا
وبعد أن هدأ الألم بعد
حوالي يوم أو يومين
شعرت أنني بخير تمامًا بعد ذلك
كان
تلوثك في مختبر CDC هو
السبب المحتمل للتأخيرات المبكرة الحرجة في بدء
الاختبار في المراسلات السياسية لـ CNN
إن سارة موراي معنا
هنا سارة ، ما الذي تتعلمه جيدًا
أنت تعرف أنه كان هناك هذا النوع من
البقعة المظلمة في فبراير عندما قام مركز السيطرة على الأمراض (CDC)
بشحن اختباره الأول لعدم
العمل مع مسؤولي الصحة العامة هؤلاء
في الولايات التي
استقبلتهم و  تبين أن
المصادر الداخلية تخبرنا أن مركز السيطرة على الأمراض كان
يكافح أيضًا لمعرفة ما كان
يحدث ولم يعرفوا ما إذا كانت
مشكلة تصنيع لم يكونوا يعرفون
ما إذا كانت مشكلة في الطريقة
التي صمموا بها اختباراتهم.  أخيرًا
في منتصف فبراير ، ذهب مسؤول من إدارة الغذاء والدواء
إلى أتلانتا للنظر في
مختبرات مراكز مكافحة الأمراض والوقاية منها وأخبرني مسؤول إداري
أن ما وجده مسؤول إدارة الغذاء والدواء
هو أن المعامل التي كان
مركز السيطرة على الأمراض يصنعها ، كانت هذه
الاختبارات ملوثة وهذا أساسًا
ما  على الأرجح تسبب
في حدوث خلل في هذه الاختبارات عندما ذهبوا إلى
الولايات ، لذا فقد استغرق الأمر بعض الوقت
بعد ذلك حتى يعمل مركز السيطرة على الأمراض وإدارة الغذاء والدواء
معًا لمعرفة كيفية عملهم
سنقوم بتجميع بعض
هذه الاختبارات بحيث لا تكون
ملوثة وكيف كانوا سيقدمون
النصح للدول لتكون قادرة على استخدام
بعض الاختبارات التي كان لديهم بالفعل في متناول اليد
كما تعلمون في هذه الفترة على الأرض ،
كان هذا  كان الوقت حرجًا حقًا ، لقد كان الوقت
الذي تحدثت فيه إلى مسؤولي الصحة العامة
حيث كانوا يعرفون على وجه الخصوص الغرب
وأماكن مثل ولاية واشنطن في
كاليفورنيا ، كانوا يعلمون أنه من
المرجح أن يكون الفيروس ينتشر
في مجتمعاتهم المحلية ومن المحتمل أن
ينتشر شخصًا إلى  - لقد شعروا نوعًا ما
وكأنهم بطة جالسة لأن
لديهم هذه القدرة المحدودة جدًا على
الاختبار وأنت تعلم أن هذه كانت مشكلة
استمرت بشكل أساسي حتى نهاية
فبراير عندما حصلوا على بعض هذا
الاختبار قيد التشغيل وما زالت
مشكلة  يعد الوصول إلى
الاختبارات على نطاق واسع مشكلة رئيسية
لا تزال الإدارة تواجهها أثناء
محاولتها إعادة فتح الاقتصاد
وهي جزء أساسي من القدرة على إعادة فتح سارة
موراي ثا
لقد كان ذلك في شهر فبراير عندما كان التلوث
في مختبر CDC هو السبب المحتمل
للتأخيرات المبكرة الحرجة وبدء
الاختبار ، كان هذا هو الرئيس في أوائل
مارس عندما زار مركز السيطرة على الأمراض في أتلانتا
واستمع إلى أي شخص
يحتاج إلى إجراء الاختبارات و  الاختبارات
جميلة ، أحب هذه الأشياء التي أحصل عليها حقًا
، يتفاجأ الناس بفهم
كل طلب ، قال هؤلاء الأطباء
كيف تعرف الكثير عن هذا الأمر ، ربما لدي
قدرة طبيعية ربما كان يجب أن
أفعل ذلك بدلاً من الترشح لمنصب
الرئيس لأكون واضحًا  بعد شهر ونصف
، لا يزال كل من يريد الاختبار
لا يمكنه الحصول على اختبار
أنت وسانجاي تعيشان في جورجيا
، حيث يمكنك الذهاب إلى مطعم ابتداءً من يوم الاثنين المقبل
، لكن
دراسة مثيرة للغاية من الصين تُظهر
مدى سهولة الفيروس  انشر
عندما تكون في الخارج لتناول العشاء مع العائلة أو
الأصدقاء ، اشرح ما تعلمناه من
هذه الدراسة ، نعم ، أعني ، أريد أن
أريكم هذا الرسم ، هذا نوع
من لقطة علوية لفا  مع طاولات المطعم الموجودة
على موقع CDC على الويب ، لا
أريد إخافة الأشخاص الذين أرغب في
تثقيفهم بهذا الأمر ، لذا فإن ثلاث مجموعات عائلية
أو ثلاث عائلات تتناول وجبة في
مطعم ، طاولة الطاولات الوسطى ،
يوجد شخص على تلك الطاولة يكون
بعد ذلك ، كانت نتيجة الاختبار إيجابية
لعدوى فيروس كورونا لا تعرف ذلك
في الوقت الذي تشعر أنه على ما يرام ولكن انظر إلى ما
يحدث هناك سيكون الخط الأحمر حيث
تمثل الدوائر الحمراء الأشخاص الذين
أصيبوا بعد ذلك من قبل شخص واحد وأربعة أشخاص
على طاولة ذلك الشخص وثلاثة
أشخاص  على الطاولة خلف هذا الشخص ،
يوجد شخصان على طاولة واحدة أكثر من
تسعة أشخاص إضافيين
يصابون بشكل عام من هذا الشخص ، هذا
هو مصدر القلق ، أعني أنك تجلس
في مطعم لديك اتصال طويل الأمد
مع الناس نتيجة لذلك
أعتقد أنهم قالوا إن المتوسط كان حوالي سا
ة أن هؤلاء الأشخاص كانوا على ات
ال ببعضهم البعض ولكن يمكنك أن يكون ذلك مج
د تذكير بمدى انتشار هذا المرض وا
مخاوف إذا كن
rt لفتح المطاعم مرة أخرى ، حيث أعلنت منظمة الصحة العالمية أن فيروس كورونا جائحة عالمي ، ارتفع عدد الوصفات الطبية التي يتم كتابتها للأدوية المضادة للقلق وفقًا لـ Express Scripts ، وهو مدير فوائد الصيدلية بعد أيام فقط من الإعلان عن وصفات الأدوية مثل Xanax و Valium. بنسبة 34 في المائة ، شهدت النساء ما يقرب من ضعف الزيادات في الرجال مع زيادة الاستخدام بنسبة 40 في المائة ، وليس من المستغرب أن يشعر الناس بالضرر الذي يلحق بصحتهم العقلية في معظم أنحاء البلاد ، حيث يتم إغلاق المدارس والبطالة في مستويات قياسية واستطلاعًا أجرته مؤسسة Kaiser Family Foundation في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر ، قال 45 في المائة من الأشخاص إن الإجهاد المرتبط بفيروس كورونا كان له تأثير سلبي على صحتهم العقلية ، وفي استطلاع منفصل من جمعية الطب النفسي الأمريكية ، قال ما يقرب من نصف المستجيبين إنهم قلقون بشأن الإصابة بالفيروس وقال 62 في المائة إنهم قلقون  حول
حصول أحد أفراد أسرتك عليه بينما
واصلنا التعامل مع الأمور التي لا يمكن التنبؤ بها ، تأكد من
أنك لا تجد
طرقًا بناءة لإدارة التوتر فحسب ، بل استمر في
التواصل مع من حولك
في اللحظة الصحية لهذا اليوم ، أنا ميليسا رايني